une réouverture au public oui mais dans
des conditions strictes établies à
l'aide d'un bureau de contrôle pour
élaborer un protocole sanitaire qui
respectent les consignes de
distanciation sociale et d'hygiène
nous avons installé du mobilier qui
vient orienter les clients suivant la
destination ivan et comme l'a par
exemple derrière moi vous avez une fille
qui part soit vers la pharmacie soit
vers la galerie et ensuite au sol des
marquages qui vient accompagné du coup
le client dans son dans son parcours
et pour entrer il faut porter un masque
comme l'indiquent la signalétique des
agents sont là pour contrôler et guider
les clients pour s'en procurer la
pharmacie a installé un stand pour en
vendre facilement aux clients qui n'en
possèderaient pas les agents vérifier
aussi le flux de personnes limitées
autour des 1700 grâce à nos caméras de
comptage qui sont répartis un petit peu
partout dans le centre on a la
possibilité de connaître à l'instant t
le nombre de personnes qui se promènent
dans la galerie et du coup dès lors que
le seuil est à temps on reçoit une
alerte sur nos téléphones et notre boîte
mail nous signalant qu on a atteint le
seuil et c'est là où du coup le rôle des
agents va être de bloquer les entrées et
on aura des fils qui vont s'organiser au
niveau des désaxés du centre d'un point
de vue visuel nettoyage et renforcer les
points sensibles comme les rampes
d'escalators sont désinfectés toutes les
deux heures et des distributeurs à gels
hydroalcooliques sont mis à disposition
des clients priorité garantir les gestes
barrière le tout dans les changes avec
les commerçants bon les informer du
dispositif qu'on allait mettre face à
leurs magasins le long de leur façade
très régulièrement il avait les
informations de manière à pouvoir déjà
se projeter savoir un petit peu ce qui
se passait et puis se positionner dans
les dents le
dans tout ce processus global si
l'espace saint quentin a établi un
protocole sanitaire globale
chaque boutique et ensuite adapter sa
pratique dans cette enseigne de
prêt-à-porter le client commence par se
laver les mains
donc on a mis une petite affiche avec
les normes de sécurité qui explique 15
personnes maximum dans le magasin avec
une bonne distance et on a mis des
flèches pour parler pour expliquer le
sens de circulation
les vendeuses et c'est d'accompagner le
client tout au long de sa visite pour
qu'une touche qu'un minimum de produits
dès qu'il veut essayer
en premier lieu on lui explique qu on a
60 jours un délai de 60 jours pour faire
et c'est remboursement à la maison ce
qui nous évite nous de nous donner
encore du travail en plus parce que au
moment de la cabine il aura toute une
procédure pour la sécurité et puis
bappoo religion une cabine sur les huit
est accessible et désinfecter par les
vendeuses entre chaque client enfin si
le client ne souhaite pas acheter ce
qu'il a essayé le vêtement sera nettoyée
à la vapeur à l'aide d'un défroisse
heures puis mis en réserve durant quatre
heures avant d'être remis en rayon
c'est beaucoup de temps consacrés à
l'hygiène en sécurité que ce soit
vraiment pour une autre bien à nous mais
aussi pour le bien le client ça rassure
le client de nous voir avec la visière
avec lui masque qu'on a du produit
nettoyant qui est vraiment partout pour
vraiment expliquer au client qu'il est
bien en sécurité chez nous et qui peut
revenir avec mon plaisir des clients qui
s'adaptent en faisant parfois du
repérage sur internet afin de chercher
une pièce précise l'espace saint quentin
a choisi d'ouvrir ce mercredi 13 et non
pas dès le 11 mai pour laisser le temps
aux commerçants de s'organiser
70% des boutiques autorisés ont levé
leur grille et le chiffre devrait
s'approcher des 100 % à la fin de la
semaine